ladies and gentlemen gather round for I
shall now reveal the magic wonders of
turing's proof
Once Upon a Time in the Enchanted realm
of mathematics there lived a clever
wizard named Alan Turing
he pondered and puzzled over the great
question can a machine like a computer
but more primitive solve any problem
given to it
so he embarked on a quest to find the
answer he conjured a Fantastical beast
called the turing machine
this creature was unlike any other for
it could read write and follow
instructions on a very long magical tape
lo and behold Turing discovered that his
creation could perform any computation a
human could as long as it was given the
right instructions but alas every
Magical Tale has its Dark Side Turing
stumbled upon a wicked problem the
halting problem
this problem asked whether a machine
could determine if a given set of
instructions would halt which is to say
stop
or run forever
I shall devise a proof declared our hero
and so Turing spun a web of logic and
reason he imagined a machine called The
halting Oracle that could solve the
halting problem if this mythical Oracle
existed it would tell us whether a set
of instructions would halt or run
forever
but Turing ever the cunning wizard
devised a diabolical paradox
what if he asked the halting Oracle were
given its own instructions as inputs
the Oracle would then have to predict
its own fate would it halt or would it
run forever
if the Oracle predicted that it would
halt it would run forever and if it
predicted that it would run forever it
would halt
the irony
turing's Paradox revealed that the
halting Oracle could not possibly exist
boom
turing's proof was complete Turing had
just proven that no machine could solve
the halting problem and therefore
machines could not solve all problems
and so with the tip of his wizard's hat
Alan Turing showed that even in the
magical world of mathematics there are
some problems that remain unsolvable
you know we have these rnns and they are
called recurrent neural networks they're
not called recursive neural networks and
Transformers are very very similar they
are Auto regressive which means you have
a model you predict a token and then you
place the the answer back into the
context and you rinse and repeat and
you're you're doing this thing called a
recurrent process but you can you can
symbolically kind of represent this as
something which looks like a recursive
function so it's F calling F calling F
calling F calling F so why is it exactly
that that is not recursive
okay
the the it's amazing that always
confusion happens because something
implies something so people assume the
implication both ways or something is a
subtype of something people assume
they're equal similarity is different
from implication implication has an
arrow so there's a it comes this way not
this way okay equivalence is equality
yeah if and only if
recursion is a recurrence but recurrence
is not recursion let me explain that
recurs as any repetitive process I mean
I can a loop is a recurrence I can go to
the ugliest way of looping just go back
here right I mean which has no sound
semantics whatsoever it doesn't have
even a sound stopping criteria and I'll
get to that that's at the heart of
recursion recurrence is I want to repeat
this thing again that's it
that's it so yes rnns are recurrent
neural networks they're not recursive
what is the huge difference
recursion is a Computing model actually
it's not a just a bit it's not a you
know a programming language we speak of
constructs if then else Loop wire
recursion is not a programming construct
recursion is a Computing model actually
recursive functions are equivalent to
Turing machines
the equivalent to Lambda calculus and
first order predicate logic this has
been proven all these computational
models are equivalent so recursion is a
computing
model it's not just a construct repeat
now what is at the heart of recursion
what what makes
okay so we agree recursion is a way of
recurring something repeating something
and there are so many other recurrence
relations uh constructs go to like I
said very simple while loop whatever
but recursion is more constrained
recursion has clear semantics for the
stopping criteria has a base case even
the way you recurse
is not anything goes
so basically recursion can be explained
in one little formula
F sum function takes input and we'll
talk about the importance of data data
as important to recursion
so I have F that takes some input and
want to compute something on that input
I have to Traverse that data structure
to its base case
right
so in the base case it depends on the
data type so for this the base case is
the emptiness for numbers it's zero for
uh trees it's Donald three and then we
compose compositionality comes in
recursion and compositionality and
induction mathematical induction are
really three things telling the same
thing all of that doesn't exist in
recurrence recurrences go back and do
this again it's that simple
recursion is different recursion is a
Computing model where I have to Define f
of base case
F of the general case which is sum G of
f of one less from the input so I keep
consuming the input
but G the final function that does
something with the recursive call result
has to also be primitive recursive
it's very it's very that the semantics
are very constrained this is not now
and it's tied to the fact that our data
types that we consume
are themselves recursive types so how do
we make a list it's either empty or some
element attached to what at least so
we're defining a list in terms of itself
people these two are related numbers I
have a zero or I have some compositional
function successor
on what a number
three what is a three it's either empty
that's my base case or it's two trees
I'm defining it three in terms of itself
that I fork together and make a bigger
three so
otherwise you don't have recursion you
have recurrence you have
can you go and do this again basically
because I don't know if I explained it
but look not very much sorry but I would
also like to add in that the stopping
condition I mean in a in an RNN you
might say I want you to produce 300
tokens but the stopping condition is is
extrinsic it's not intrinsic to the
problem exactly in recursion you you
take the data and you break it down into
smaller sub problems and in recursion
the stopping criteria is a is a semantic
criteria it's a function of the data and
the function itself in in recurrence I
can stop whenever I want I can say
actually I can say do this 200 times I
don't care or or I can say yeah okay
exactly because um because like the
naive take on it is just that well in
something like an RNN you you have you
don't have an expandable memory you have
a fixed amount of compute either in time
or in a Transformer architecture you
have a fixed amount of compute um so
it's actually related to infinite
objects well yeah I want to get there in
just a second so so the other thing is
um as Chomsky does in his hierarchy you
can also think of the class of languages
which are producible from from these
models and they truly recursive function
can produce what he would call
recursively innumerable languages
whereas tail recursion on an RNN would
not be able to do that but it then
brings us to this key issue coming back
to Chomsky is actually getting
recurrence or at the bottom of this
hierarchy regular expressions or if you
want finite6 machines so I can because
they have recurrence but they don't have
recursion
exactly so there was this recent um deep
mine paper talking about a mapping
between the Chomsky hierarchy and
different models and you have standard
MLPs which are just finite State
automotives and rnns can produce regular
languages and you go all the way up to
the stack to this recursively
innumerable languages which can be
recognized by Turing machines so the
Chomsky hierarchy is actually about the
class of languages which you can
recognize with the model and then it
gets me to two points so Chomsky spoke a
lot about the importance of recursion in
our language and a turing machine can
recognize recursively enumerable
languages right and then someone will
say well well I've got these
Transformers models and they can
approximate recursively innumable
languages to a certain level of
complexity probably within the Horizon
which is ever seen in language therefore
why do we not need the Turing machines
right okay so we go back to approximate
which is related to our first argument
that probably
what large language models have been
able to do is pretty much cover most of
language for all practical reasons okay
so we're talking about
the approximate approximation you can
never go if you don't have a real
recursion over infinite objects all
you're doing is approximation but can
you get to a point where your
approximation is almost
close to the whole thing that's the big
question remains to be seen and in my
mind it's an open question actually uh
apparently as far as syntax they've
proved that that they you know
apparently I don't need
a context-free grammar that can handle
an infinite number of sentences the set
of is infinite I don't need that they
prove that in in a way I mean I don't
know if
but since
but the grammar produces generates
uh it's a it's a recursively enumer I
can I can always enumerate in this set
another valid sentence they've learned
that infinite set
they've approximated that infinitecept
okay I mean I was speaking with uh
Professor Chris Elliott Smith the other
day and um and he asserted that rnns
that are incomplete that they're not
touring completely but but the thing is
though um look anything anything that
does an infinite tape or memory right
uh yeah but the thing is like even even
the the turing machine it's an abstract
mathematical concept because a lot of
people we've spoken to even like Pedro
Domingos they hate it when we cite
Infinity right because they say well I
know you haven't really got but but the
thing is what you would say Walid is
that there's something very powerful
about being able to represent an
infinite object with a finite object
with a finite specification right I mean
can you give me an example though of of
course it didn't do it I've been a
practical example that we use all of us
our All Tech people use every day right
your your favorite compiler is what Java
python I don't know C sharp you're a
doctor
okay okay but it does it doesn't matter
they're all equivalent anyway so let's
say
um python right
okay because probably our crowd is more
python people right so python
uh it doesn't matter what version of
your compiler you have if you like a
valid Python program the python compiler
will not say sorry that's not this is
not in my set
I mean we we deal with infinity every
day I I I I wrote something about that I
can't believe someone as brilliant as
Dominico uh will will say something like
that his python compiler or his Java
compiler I don't know what he uses is
ready for how many programs infinite
that's a practical Infinity that's not a
an abstract Infinity the python compiler
has to be ready for any valid program
and any here is what Infinity
that's a practical infinitely as
practical as you can get now this
applies to many other problems and and
this is the power of logic and recursion
this didn't come from nowhere we were
talking about recursion just a second
ago it's related to Infinity I can
Define
an infinite object which is what in this
case or the set of all valid python
programs guys this is very simple I I
managed to get I managed to get first
year computer science students to to get
this
I am defining in a finite way called the
grammar an infinite set of python
programs that my compiler now is ready
for
that's practical Infinity on your
machine every morning
so I I agree with that I don't I don't
know why the concept is that strange
well let me let me say a slightly
different way so yeah there are an
infinite set of possible programs
obviously there's an infinite set of
language obviously Chomp Chomsky said
there's it's it's an oxymoron to talk
about the probability of a sentence but
so the thing I wanted to get to though
is practically Chris Elliott Smith said
well
um we can we can approximate these
recursively innumerable languages
language language natural language is a
recursively innumerable language but is
there a
um is there a difference between having
a real turing machine Traverse this
Infinite Space right because let's say
we've got bounded time in both right on
the um on the rnm we've got bounded time
on the turing machine we've got
boundaries
it's not about time and it's not about
space people tell me but we're finite
people we never speak everything and
then that's not where the infinity is
the infinity is the antithesis of
probability meaning you cannot state
with any certainty what I might say next
so you have to be ready for how many
infinite let me explain it this way Tim
it's very simple that's the magic of
recursion and logic
when I write a python compiler I cannot
write it in such a way that hopefully
Tim will never write this program
I have to be ready for an infinite set
of valid python programs that's where
the infinity is it's not about time and
space we this compiler might not be used
by anyone
forget it
let me phrase it slightly differently so
with with python it makes sense we have
to have a compiler which can recognize
an infinite number of python programs
with natural language obviously but
we've just been saying with natural
language that's not the case
have we not I'm saying they've done a
good job approximating remains to be
seen look Tim we haven't put this thing
in actual use yet in the wild
okay let's be careful I mean and and
most people I have to say most people
are testing it they're testing it to be
amazed and they're liking what they see
and they're overlooking all the I don't
wanna use bad language no no the the the
debate is not over by by any means so
when we put these things in the wild
like a person walking the streets of San
Francisco and someone stops them and say
hello they cannot predict what they will
ask with any probability this is what
the genius of Chomsky speaking of the
probability of any sentence is not just
a meaningless notion it doesn't it
doesn't I mean you cannot predict what I
might ask you next forget it you're
because you're picking from an infinite
set anything over infinity is zero so
your your probability means nothing
and
the python compiler
example applies to language applies to
SQL you know a SQL compiler databases
that applies to all computation
I have to be ready for an infinite set
of
objects that you might throw at me that
any is infinity
I I can't Infinity is not a theoretical
concept it's a real concept actually
the halting problem reduces to infinite
regress
what is the halting problem I can never
write a program P to test another
program if it terminates why because
what if my testing program doesn't
terminate
if my testing program doesn't terminate
now I have two possibilities it doesn't
terminate or while it was running my
program it didn't terminate so I need to
write a program that tests if this one
terminates
it goes to Infinity it's infinite
regress the halting problem or most
paradoxes
unless you want to approximate again you
can approximate Infinity with
approximating infinity doesn't it sound
silly
cool doctor
thank you so much for joining us always
fun always fun